- Well, they were so fed
up like I was so, you know,
I'm a small business guy
who, the previous governor,
Martin O'Malley had raised
taxes 43 times in a row.
And it had crushed our economy.
We had lost 10,000
businesses and 100,000 jobs
and people were fleeing the
state in all directions.
And it was frustrating
to a lot of people.
And it was to me as a
small business owner.
And it didn't matter what
your party affiliation was,
people were leaving, and a
Gallup poll came out that said
47% of all Marylanders
wanted to leave the state.
And that was kind of the straw
that broke the
camel's back for me.
(warm instrumental music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and this
is "The Rubin Report."
As always guys, don't
forget to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and
click that notification bell.
And joining me today is the
62nd governor of the great state
of Maryland and the
author of "Still Standing:
Surviving, Cancer,
Riots, a Global Pandemic
and the Toxic Politics
that Divide America."
Governor Larry Hogan, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Well, thank you, Dave.
It's really great to be with
you, thanks for having me.
- My pleasure, that is
quite a title of a book.
I mean, you have got, your
title is a book unto itself.
- Right.
- Which I thought would be
and interesting--
- Well, you made it
all the way through so I
was impressed with that.
So thank you.
- I've become a master
of the teleprompter,
but actually I thought that
would be an interesting place
to start because the book
is coming out this week
and you actually made a whole
bunch of additions to the book
because of what's
happening right now.
So I thought that
might be the right spot
for us to kick off here.
- Right, yeah.
- Dave, it was already a kind
of a long title to begin with
because we were trying to cover
a lot of important topics,
you know, and I was covering,
when I was elected
kind of overcame,
I was the biggest upset
in America in 2014
in a very blue state.
I was immediately hit with
dealing with riots in Baltimore
and then life-threatening
cancer and, you know,
we had lot of interesting
stories to write about.
I really wanted to
talk a little bit,
it's not a heavy political read,
but I wanted to talk a
little bit about, you know,
the divisive politics today
and some of my thoughts
on where we ought to be heading.
And we put together this
book sort of a February-ish
timeframe was when we
were finished with it.
And it was going to come
out a little earlier
and then the pandemic,
we kind of put it on hold
and asked the
publisher to hold it.
They would only
hold it until now.
And they asked us
if we would add
some more current activities,
'cause I was dealing
with this crisis and we
added about five chapters
on the pandemic and
I think it makes it
kinda more
interesting, and I tell
some pretty straightforward
stories about what we've
been dealing with,
but I'm hoping
people will find it interesting.
- Yeah, so I want to go into
each of the specific topics
that you break down the title,
but let's start with
the pandemic stuff,
because as you just mentioned,
you are a Republican governor
of a largely blue state.
If I'm not mistaken, only
two Republican governors
have ever been
reelected in Maryland,
in its entire history.
So maybe we should
start there first.
What's it like being an
outsider governor, whether it's,
you know, a red
guy in a blue state
or a blue guy in a red state,
just what's that like
first before pandemic time
and then we'll talk about that.
- Sure, yeah, so I, you know,
I'm a lifelong
small business guy.
Never held elective office
until I was elected governor.
Our state was, it has the
highest democratic registration
of any state in America.
In 2014, I got elected.
It was kind of a shock.
I mean, nobody expected me to.
I came from nowhere
and we weren't even
on the radar screen.
It was kind of, I was the least
likely to succeed, I think.
Nobody thought I was
going to be governor,
but I pulled together a
coalition of, you know,
all the few Republicans
we had in our state
along with a bunch
of independents
and Democrats and I got elected.
And then I'm governing in a
state that's a fairly liberal
Democratic state
with the legislature
that's 70%, you know,
Democrats in both chambers,
every single statewide elected
official is a Democrat.
I'm only the second Republican
50 years to be elected,
and the second one to be
reelected in 242 years.
So it's look, I think one
of the things I've learned
in a situation like that is
that you've got to figure out
a way to work with people on
the other side of the aisle.
And it may be different if
you're, say, a Republican
in a red state or you're a
Democrat in a blue state,
you don't have to develop those
relationships and you don't
have to maybe
compromise or find a way
to reach that middle
ground, you know,
where you can all work together.
So maybe out of necessity
to get things done
I had to be more pragmatic and
figure out, how do you reach
common sense solutions and
actually fix some problems?
And it turns out that's
what a lot of people seem
to want because you know, a lot
of Democrats and Republicans
and independents seemed to
like it and they reelected me.
And you know, we seem to
be making some progress.
- Are you telling me that people
vote you guys in
to fix problems?
Is that what it's all about?
- Well, I know, Dave, it
sounds like a strange concept
in politics today 'cause
we don't see a lot of that,
but I really do think it's
what a lot of people want.
I mean, you know, we can
talk about the politics
on the right and the left.
I think most people,
regardless of where they fall
on the spectrum, they really
do want the people they elect
to office, regardless of
which side of the aisle
they come from, they
just want people
to get to work and
get things done.
And I think they're frustrated
with the political process
and the fact that they
see a lot of divisiveness
and dysfunction, they
don't think people
are getting the job done.
- You mentioned that you
were a small businessman
before going into politics.
My sense is that the
future of politics,
probably on either side,
although I think probably more
on the Republican side is
that the day of the
longterm politician,
the guy who comes up
through the system is over
and that the future
will be people
who built their own
businesses, who innovated,
maybe were in the tech world,
that those will be the
future politicians.
Do you think that gave you
unique a unique way of looking
at the world that has been
relevant for governing?
- You know, well, first
of all, I agree with you.
I think that is what
we're gonna see.
It's what we should see.
I mean, I've, for a long
time sort of been arguing
against career
politicians who spend
their entire professional
lives in elective office.
And I think it's what the
founding fathers originally
had in mind, you know,
about people just leaving
whatever it was they normally
did and going in and serving
for a while in public service.
I actually, you
know, I'm the chair
of the National
Governors Association
and active in the Republican
Governors Association.
And a lot of my colleagues
have similar profiles
and backgrounds, not all
of them, many of them
are not lifelong politicians.
Many of them have
business backgrounds.
And I think it may be a
sort of a new phenomenon,
but I'm not alone
in that regard.
And I think maybe in
the governor's races,
you may send somebody off to
Washington that's, you know,
been a politician, but when
you're deciding who the CEO
or the chief executive is
going to be to run your state,
you know, they want
to pick somebody
that's kind of
competent and able
to run things and
get things done.
And so you see, see a lot
of business backgrounds
in the folks that are
running the states.
- Yeah, it's one--
- I think it's helped me a lot
I mean, you know, I knew a
little bit about government
and I knew some
stuff about politics,
but the business background,
you know, my whole career
was about trying to
bring people together
to get things done,
and it turns out
that's actually a valuable thing
to have in government, too,
(laughs) you know.
- You don't say.
Accomplishing stuff.
- Yeah, I mean, strange.
- And getting things done.
- Nobody ever
figured that out before.
- Do you find Maryland
to be a particularly
unique case these days
because of the proximity
to Washington, D.C.
where so many of the longtime
bureaucrats and the people
that have just been
in the system forever,
a ton of them live in
Maryland, obviously.
And that maybe
filters a little bit
of what the political
life is like there.
- Maybe to a certain extent.
I mean, one of our
largest population centers
is in metropolitan Washington,
but we're a pretty
diverse state.
You know, we've got the
Washington Metropolitan Area,
the Baltimore Metropolitan
Area, but we've got, you know,
some pretty dense areas
we've got, you know,
but we've got suburban areas,
very rural areas of our state,
about 70% of our state is rural.
And so we're kind
of a microcosm.
I mean, we're
America in miniature.
We have a little bit of the
same things that everybody has.
We have probably a
higher percentage
of federal government employees.
So we actually have more people
that are in the private sector
that maybe have some kind
of government contracting
affiliation, but it may change.
We're a little bit more
liberal and a little bit more
Democratic leaning
as a result of that.
It made it more challenging
for me to get elected,
but you know, we've
been able to win over
some of those folks,
which is common sense.
- What was going on there
before you were elected
that a blue state would say,
oh, let's let this guy in
who's not a career politician,
who's cobbling together this
kind of strange coalition.
- Yeah, well, they were
so fed up, like I was.
So I'm a small business
guy who, previous governor
Martin O'Malley had raised
taxes 43 times in a row.
And it had crushed our economy.
We had lost 10,000
businesses and 100,000 jobs
and people were fleeing the
state in all directions.
And it was frustrating
to a lot of people.
And it was to me as a
small business owner.
And it didn't matter what
your party affiliation was,
people were leaving.
A Gallup poll, came out that
said 47% of all Marylanders
wanted to leave the state,
and that was kind of
the straw that broke
the camel's back for me.
We were 49th out of 50 States
in economic performance.
So I was frustrated enough
to do something crazy,
like say, I've had enough,
I'm gonna run for governor.
And it was the point where
Democrats said, you know,
I'm a lifelong Democrat.
I've never considered voting
for a Republican in my life,
but this guy is
starting to make sense.
And I focused on the economic
issues and talked about,
you know, we were gonna
cut taxes and regulations
and focus on growing
our private sector
and trying to put more
people back to work,
and it's exactly what we did.
We had the biggest economic
turnaround in America.
We had more businesses open
and put more people to work
than ever before in the
history of the state.
And we got things done even
with our Democratic legislature.
- Do you think bottom
line, when you get rid
of all the other issues that
you're dealing with all day,
that if you as a governor
can keep the economy chugging
and keep people at work that
you've basically done your job?
- Well, you know, we're
wrestling with all kinds
of really tough issues, Dave.
When you're governor of
the state, as I mentioned,
you know, we're
dealing with, you know,
close to a $50 billion
budget and, you know,
60 some thousand employees,
we have to provide all
these different services.
There are so many
different issues,
but really it is, we're
dealing with educating folks
and handling transportation
and, you know, law enforcement,
all these multitude of
things, but the focus
that brought everybody
together in our state
that they could agree on,
they could argue about
various different issues.
But the one thing
they all agreed on
was the pocket book issues.
And that's how I put together,
I put a group together
called Change Maryland.
It was a nonpartisan
citizen organization.
And we had just as many
Democrats and independents
as Republicans, and
they were just saying,
let's focus on these issues.
Let's not argue about all
these other things right now.
Let's just focus on these.
And we brought
together a coalition.
It turned out to be
a winning coalition.
And, and you know, when
people say, how did you get,
you know, suburban women and
how do you get minorities
and how do you get
Democrats and independents
to vote for a Republican?
But I think it's one of the
things that Republican party
is gonna have to think
about, how do we reach out
to a wider group of people
in order to win
elections in the future
so we can be in the position
of making decisions?
- Yeah, so I want
to get more to that
and the sort of pure
political side in a minute,
but let's talk about
what's going on--
- I didn't mean to get too
political on you, Dave.
- (laughs) A governor
getting political?
I can't believe it.
- Yeah, let's not
do that anymore.
- Yeah, yeah, let's talk about
what's going on now though,
because you know, there's been,
I think the major conversation
really at a high level
is sort of what the federal
government is supposed to do
related to coronavirus
and what the state governments
are supposed to do.
I suspect I generally know
your thoughts on this,
but what do you think your
job as a governor is right now
and what is not your job?
What is the job of the
federal government?
- Well, that's a great question.
Look, I think the governors
are on the front lines
of this crisis,
and we ought to be.
We are out there, we're closest
to the people's problems.
We're working together
with our local governments.
And we're trying to really
address these issues
that are on the ground
in our individual states.
And each of our
states are different.
We're going after, you know,
the different situations on
the ground in our states,
but there was a major, there
were certain big things
that only the federal
government could do well.
So, you know, early
on in this crisis,
the federal government could
have taken more of a role
in an overall testing strategy.
They did, you know, they
were a little bit, I think,
behind the eight ball
in the early stages.
And I talk about this
in my book a little bit,
in March and April when they
weren't taking it as seriously.
I mean, there were people in
the administration who were.
I think the president
downplayed it a little more
than he should have,
and they didn't develop
a lot of national strategies.
We had 50 individual
state strategies.
I'm not saying states shouldn't
have had the authority
and independence to be able
to make their own decisions,
but certain things like,
we shouldn't have 50 States
competing with one another
in a constrained market
for desperately needed supplies,
competing with the
federal government
and trying to acquire
things all over the world.
So on testing and
contact tracing, and some
of the major issues that the
power of the federal government
could really have helped
with the pandemic.
And in some respects
they're getting better,
but certain things
the federal government
can just do better.
- Can you talk a little bit
about how you specifically
make decisions when it comes
to lockdown or the rest of it?
Because as you know, I'm here
in Los Angeles, California.
We've had rolling lockdowns
then they, kicked in again.
Last week I was actually out
to lunch for the first time
in weeks and as I
was having lunch,
we got the notification
on my phone that said,
the restaurants are
closing in two hours.
Now everything's closed again.
And I've been very
critical of Gavin Newsom,
our governor here, not
necessarily because
of what he's doing rather
than the messaging.
It seems like they just,
they just give edicts.
They never say, well,
we've seen these
numbers change this way.
We know this behavior
changed this or that.
It's just, oh, now
we're locking down.
We'll see you in August,
we'll see you in September.
And that's what I'm sort
of more concerned about.
Can you talk a little bit
about how you message things
and how you actually
come to the decisions?
- Yeah, it was great
question, Dave,
and you hit on a couple
of really good points.
First of all, I agree that the
messaging has been a problem.
You know, I think a
lot of the governors
are not messaging very well.
And frankly, I think that's
where the president's
biggest weaknesses have
been, on the messaging side.
I've tried to be just very
direct and upfront and provide
as much information as possible
because I think most people,
whether the news is good or
bad, if you're just, you know,
frank with them and you supply
the facts in a situation
like this, when we're dealing
with, you know, in some cases,
life and death matters in
a serious health crisis
and a global pandemic and an
economic collapse potentially,
people want to know the
facts and they want to know
why you're making decisions.
So, you know, I think I'm
not the only one doing it,
but there are a number,
the governors who have been
more direct and open
and transparent,
I think have been
the most successful.
On the decision making
process, I just tried to get,
you know, we had to make
decisions really quickly
in this thing because it wasn't
like we have deliberations
with our legislature
and let's talk about it
and form a committee.
You know, this was happening
really fast at the beginning.
As we were spiking, we were
seeing things happening
in Italy, in New York and people
dying and bodies stacked up
in overflowing hospitals and
we were hearing these things
about two million
potential deaths.
And so we were, time
was of the essence
to make some decisions.
You had to make the
right decisions quickly.
You couldn't hesitate, but I
wanted to get the best advice
I could from the
smartest people.
We put together a taskforce
of really smart doctors
and scientists and
business people.
And I just tried to
get the best input,
listen to everyone and
then make decisions
without hesitating and then
communicate it really well
to the people about,
this is what we're doing
and here's why, and here's
how it's going to help.
And so we took very
aggressive and early actions,
did things that I never would
have imagined ever doing,
but it helped us
flatten the curve.
I mean, our numbers
are really good.
Our economy's really good.
We took early and
aggressive action.
We had a safe and effective
reopening and, you know,
we're now, you know,
way down from our peak
that happened about
more than 90 days ago.
We've opened up
98% of our economy.
And our unemployment
at 8% is staggering,
but it's, you know, some are
two and a half times worse,
better than the rest of
the country and our numbers
while, you know, we we've
had a number of deaths
and we had the same
problems other people had,
we're in great shape right now.
- Yeah, on a personal
note as a guy
that didn't want to
always get into politics,
when you have to make
those decisions about,
okay, we're going to
extend the lockdown,
we're gonna lift the lock
down, whatever it may be,
what was that like for you?
'Cause I think people think
of people think of politicians
sort of as robots, like, oh,
they just make the choices.
- Yeah.
- But, yeah.
- No, it was really,
really hard, Dave.
You know, I've been through
and I talk about some of these,
you know, personal and
professional struggles,
battles that I've been
through in my book.
And I share some of that,
you know, what it was like,
and all the things
that I had to deal with
on a personal level or
what battles I went through
as governor or getting
elected governor.
This was the hardest thing
that I think I've had
to deal with, something we
never imagined dealing with.
And it wasn't just, you know,
I went through a cancer
battle where I was worried
about how my family was going
to take it, or, you know,
I was dealing with
other cancer patients.
This was, I was worried
about six million people
in my state, and my decisions
were going to impact
not only their health,
but I'm a lifelong
small business guy, ran for
governor with the sole purpose
of creating jobs and
helping small businesses,
and decisions I
was going to make
were going to impact, it was
going to cost people jobs
and hurt their small businesses,
or people were going to die.
It was a really hard
situation to be put in.
And, frankly, the president,
et cetera, left it up.
He said, it's up
to the governors.
And we were getting, you
know, open up and then,
you know, but you
have to shut down.
He was giving, the
administration was
given us advice.
You have to do these things,
or we're gonna have
two million deaths.
And then, you know,
messaging the opposite stuff
the next day so it was, we
were in tough situations,
but I think, and everybody
made different decisions,
but on a personal level, I mean,
there's been very little
sleep for five months
and a lot of stress.
And you've got people that
are mad at you either way,
no matter what you do, you
can't make everybody happy.
And, you know, I just tried
to do the very best I could,
based on the information
I had and, you know,
tried to do the best thing
for the people in the state.
- Yeah, so let's talk about the
other thing that's going on.
'Cause there is
another thing going on.
There's always a lot of things,
but there's sort of two main
ones going on at the moment.
And the second one obviously
is, I guess the best way
you describe it is
either the racial unrest
or the protesting
or the rioting,
just the whole
conversation we're having.
The toppling of, of monuments.
Now, again, you're in
Maryland, D.C. is right there.
An awful lot of monuments,
an awful lot of history
is right in your backyard.
You know, you've
got Baltimore there,
which has its own set
of set of problems.
So I'm not even going
to ask you a question.
I'm just going to just
pass all that off to you.
- Toss it out.
- Take it away, yeah.
- Yeah, well, that's, you're
just gonna let me tee it up.
You know, you look at
the title of the book.
It's like riots, you
know, cancer, riots,
a global pandemic.
I dealt with this and I
talk about this a lot.
And there's real parallels
to what's going on right now
with the riots, the violence,
the unrest, the protests,
however you want to describe it.
There's a little bit
of all of that going on
across America in
different cities.
In 2015, right after I
became governor, we had,
I'd only been
governor for 89 days.
And we had the worst violence
in 47 years break out
in our largest city in Baltimore
after the death of Freddie Gray.
And, you know, in the
very first few hours
in Baltimore City,
400 businesses were
burned and looted
and destroyed, 127
police and firefighters
were injured and hospitalized.
The city police force was
overwhelmed and the city
was really having no
ability to respond.
It was sort of out of control.
And as governor, I had
declared a state of emergency,
sent in 4,000 members
of the National Guard
and 1,000 police
officers into the city.
We allowed peaceful protests
to go on for a week,
but we shut down the violence.
We stopped the
burning, the looting
and all the damage
that was being done.
And, you know, I
write about this,
I think I have five chapters
on this in the book.
I walked the streets of
Baltimore for a solid week
to listen to people,
that was hugging people
who lost their businesses
and their homes.
I was meeting with
community leaders.
I was talking to
faith-based leaders.
I was walking the streets where
Freddie Gray's neighborhood.
I was, you know, I was
dealing with the crisis,
but also trying to
lower the temperature.
And I think we found the
balance of, I call it, you know,
Reagan's peace through strength.
We sent enough people in there
to keep the citizens safe,
but not allow the
violence and destruction
without further
inflaming, you know,
the anger and violence by
moving too aggressively.
You know, we just, you know,
if you were protesting in
the streets, it was OK.
If you're throwing rocks
and setting things on fire,
we're going to arrest you.
And I think the
mistakes that were made
in some of the large cities
today, by just letting,
you know, mob rule takeover,
and just not to respond
at all was a big mistake.
There's obviously
legitimate frustrations
in the black community
and I was very proud
of actually Baltimore this time,
as we're seeing things
erupt everywhere,
it was mostly very peaceful
protests without the violence
and destruction this time.
And I think our police,
state police, National Guard,
and the city police in
Baltimore did a really good job.
And I think the citizens
here did a good job.
They were actually pointing
out the handful of, you know,
violent folks that
weren't even from the city
and saying, hey, stop this.
They wanted to just peacefully
express their frustrations.
But it's something we've
got to get a handle on.
And I, you know, I understand
both sides of the argument,
but I talk about this
extensively in the book.
I think you've got to, you know,
we've got to find the way
to get this under control
while addressing
some of the concerns.
- How miserable of a
decision is it for you
when something's going
down in one of your cities,
in this case, Baltimore,
where you have to then
bring in the National Guard
or something else where I know
it's your preference to let
the mayor hopefully do his
or her job and make sure that
they take care of business.
But as we're seeing in a lot
of these states right now,
I mean, we're really seeing
it in Portland right now.
The mayor seems either unwilling
or unable to do anything.
And now we've got,
we've got in effect,
we've got federal troops
in the streets of Portland.
- Yeah, they're making,
the mayor, I think
by not taking action early,
I think they made a mistake.
And I was very
prepared for that.
I kind of saw what
might be happening.
Our team, we stood up
the Maryland Emergency
Management Agency
in about a week in advance.
We saw things potentially
bubble up a couple days earlier.
I was ready with
executive orders,
you know, already prepared.
I've been in constant
contact with the city.
The first violence that
violence had broke out
I was on the phone with
the mayor saying, you know,
this doesn't look like
you have it under control.
I took action within a
matter of hours to come in
and back up the
beleaguered police
that were overwhelmed
in the city.
And I think, you know, that
early and aggressive action,
again, it's sort of
like this pandemic.
There's no time to delay and
hesitate and to be too passive.
But again, we didn't go
in there and aggressively,
you know, cause further
escalation of the problem.
We just went in there to
keep the citizens safe.
And they were very
appreciative of it.
You know, the people
in Baltimore were like,
thank you, because
they were scared.
They were really worried
about this violence
and the people trying
to take over their city.
- Are you hearing from
just regular people
that they're really worried
about the sort of mob rule
that seems to be taking effect,
regardless of whether
you're for statues stand,
the fact that they are just
coming down all over the place,
as opposed to let's,
you know, let's vote
and make a decision
or have, you know,
some process related to the law.
I mean, whether you
want them down or not,
I think most people agree
that tearing them down
is not legal.
- Right.
At the very least, are regular
people bringing that up
to you, that the
rule of law seems
to be up in the
air at the moment?
- Well to me, I'm shocked that
this is even a debate really.
I mean, we had, we did have,
although I was praising
Baltimore this time
about the lack of violence,
we did have a situation where
in Little Italy,
we had somebody, a
smaller group of folks
tore down a Christopher
Columbus statue.
Now I'm not here to
debate the merits
of whether Christopher Columbus
was a great guy or not,
but there's no way that we
should encourage, you know,
mobs to be able to tear down
whatever piece of art
or history they want to
instead of going before the
city council and arguing
why they think they
maybe should put that
in a museum or do
something else.
We actually had a city
councilman member in Baltimore
while they were tearing
down that statue
that tweeted something
like, you know,
maybe they should consider
going down and tearing down
another statue that
was built to honor
fallen police officers, a
memorial that was put up
by the families of, I mean,
it was just unbelievable
that we're having these
kinds of discussions.
I understand the debate
about some of these statutes.
Maybe we really should
take a look at, you know,
making a decision
to remove them.
And I think that's a debate.
That's an argument
and a discussion
we definitely should have.
And some of them,
I understand why
they may be offensive to some
folk, but you can't just allow
mobs to decide which ones
they want to tear down.
- Yeah, well, we seem to be
in this sort of mob moment,
I suppose you could call it.
What are you seeing between
the tension right now
between the Republicans
and the Democrats?
You strike me as,
what I would say
is a pretty moderate Republican.
You can either, you can
assess that statement
however you'd like, but
that's what you strike me as.
What I'm worried about
is that, you know,
I don't know how much
you know about me,
but I was a lifelong
Democrat lefty progressive
until the last couple of years.
- I know.
- And I'm worried about--
- And then you saw the light.
- (laughs) And here we are,
right, and here we are,
but what I am worried about
is that my former
side, so to speak,
and I don't like doing it
in sides but, you know,
there's only so many ways we
can talk about these things,
that my former side,
that it seems like
if you don't go fully
woke, if you don't go fully
to where the Bernie
AOC energy is
that they're just
going to take you out.
And are you seeing that
at a state level, too?
- Oh yeah, no, there's
no question about that.
And so, yeah, look, I'm
a lifelong Republican.
I was a chairman of Youth for
Reagan and I was in, you know,
I would say most of my life,
I would be considered a
conservative, a Republican.
Now I guess they call me a
moderate because, you know,
I really try to avoid the
extremes of either party.
And I think one of the
problems we have today is that,
you know, first of all,
I like to avoid the
divisive, angry rhetoric.
And because I want to work
together to get things done,
that makes me a
moderate, I guess.
I don't think, you know,
trying to get things done
and finding compromise,
you know, is a dirty word.
Compromise isn't a bad thing.
Doing nothing is a bad
thing, getting nothing done,
standing up, I'm going to
stick to my principles,
but I'm not gonna
accomplish anything.
But, you know, right now I
think the Democratic Party
is moving too far to the left.
And I think the Republican Party
is now shrinking their base
down to not appeal
to enough people.
And there's a growing
a number of people
that are either moderate or
right of center, left of center,
who are somewhat frustrated
with the entire
political process.
And they're like, this
is the best we can do?
And you know, they're not really
on the extremes of
either party in mind.
You see polling
that says, you know,
maybe 15% consider
themselves very progressive
or very conservative
on each side.
And everybody else is
somewhere in the middle.
And they're saying--
- How do we fix that?
- Exhausted majority, that goes,
why can't we get
somebody normal?
And why can't we
get something done?
- So how do you fix
it, how do you fix it?
It's hard to fix it, but I
mean, part of it is, I mean,
it's a broke, look some
people have given up
and they're like, we're never
gonna fix the broken politics.
You know, I would argue that
some of that we've been,
and I talk about this in
my book, I think you can,
you know, lower the temperature,
try to avoid the
divisive rhetoric,
try to find ways to actually
work in a pragmatic way.
But there's also structural
things that we have to do.
I mean, we got to get
rid of gerrymandering
and the way our primary
process works only
the people on the
extremes win the primary.
There's no competitive
races anywhere
in the general
elections typically.
And we end up with, you know,
people in Congress
that are, you know,
not ever going to
agree on anything
and not ever meet in
the middle on anything.
So I think we've got to kind
of work on, how do we elect,
you know, people that
are willing to go down
and work together
and get, I mean,
I think people are frustrated
whether they are on the right
or the left about the fact
that nobody can
get anything done.
- Yeah.
- I'm willing to
work with anybody.
I'm kind of on the, get to
work and get things done
school of politics.
I don't care if you're a
Democrat or Republican,
if you'll help me
fix the problem.
- Yeah, and that's sort
of been your position
with Trump, right?
Because you've obviously,
I mean, even here
you've been critical of
some of his responses,
but then there's
some other things
that you think he's
done pretty well.
- Yeah, no, well,
look, I've never been,
I'm one of those people
you've never seen me as one
of the guys that's on constantly
criticizing the president
for no reason, never done that.
Never been going after
him in a personal way.
There's plenty of people on
TV that'll do that constantly,
but I'm also never, I'm not
one of those Republicans
that's afraid to speak
up if I disagree,
which, you know,
a lot of them are.
I just pretty much, like,
I tell it like it is.
I mean, I, you know, I
respect, I praise the president
when they do something right.
And, I agree with him
when I think, you know,
he's in the right on
something, but I always say,
if they haven't
done something well,
I'm not going to just
sit down and shut up
and then keep it to myself.
And there are a lot of
Republicans who agree with me,
but they're afraid to say it.
- Does it ever sort of kill you
that like a nice guy like you,
that Trump was willing
to do all the things
that maybe somebody like
you wouldn't have done?
And when I say someone like you,
I mean, someone like me, too,
that there is sort of more
moderate people that maybe just
won't do the things that it
takes to win at that level.
It's not even a judgment.
It just sort of is that
we're all sort of wired
a little differently, we
all take the temperature
of the room a little
bit differently.
- Yeah, you know, look,
I'm willing to stand up
and fight for the things
that I believe in,
but I'm not for divisiveness
and dysfunction.
And I would argue
that people liked me.
And I look at our record
over the past six years,
we've been more effective
and can get more things done.
I'm not sure, and it's not
talking about philosophy now,
or we're not agreeing with many
of the president's
positions, philosophy
I would agree with
on the economy.
And I think he's done some
things that are pretty good,
but he hasn't gotten a
lot done in Congress.
And some of it is
that personality,
and some of it is, I think
he could be more successful.
I think sometimes he's
his own worst enemy
and he could be more effective
if he tried to do some things
a little differently.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, I get it, you
gotta stand up and fight,
but sometimes that's
not the skillset
that you need to use
to get things done.
- Hmm, let's talk
about the personal side
of the book a little bit.
You talk about battling
cancer, so let's talk about it.
- Yeah, so I talked
about the riots.
You know, that you know,
right after I became governor.
And I went through that.
I'd been through my first
legislative session,
which is a 90-day session
here in Annapolis.
And I was on my first
trade mission to Asia.
I went to Korea,
China, and Japan.
And I noticed a
lump in my throat
and I was feeling
some aches and pains.
And I decided that, you know,
go to a doctor to check it out.
I just wasn't feeling terrible.
I just felt a little
rundown and a few things
that I'd noticed, and
I had three doctors,
come in and tell me
that I had very advanced
and aggressive cancer.
From my neck to my groin
I had 50-some tumors,
and it was a rapidly
growing, life-threatening,
large B cell
non-Hodgkin's lymphoma.
And it was pretty grim news.
They told me, I'd been
governor for five months.
It was Friday of Father's Day
weekend when I got this news.
And I, you know,
I had to go home
and it hit me out of the blue.
I had no idea, I mean, you
know, that this was going on.
I don't know how these things
were growing inside of me.
And I didn't know, I'd
been through all that work,
winning the campaign, going
through all that, you know,
really working hard, you
know, 10, 12 hour days,
seven days a week,
and still working
like the Energizer bunny.
But I, you know, the
hardest part was,
how am I gonna explain
this to my family?
I went home and told my
wife and my three daughters
who were there for
Father's Day weekend.
And then I had to explain
it to my 80-year-old dad
who was over for Father's Day.
And then I went and had
to explain it to my staff
who had worked so
hard and, just,
you know, helping us put
the administration together.
And then I had to tell the
six million people in Maryland
who just put their faith in me.
And it was a, it was
a difficult thing.
I was going through 24
hour a day chemotherapy.
I went through about
an 18-month battle.
I was very open and transparent.
And I mean, I shared
I was going through.
And it was, you know, it an
incredible, you know, I really,
I think I have a different
perspective on life
and it made me realize
the important things.
And I got to meet
some incredible people
who were going through much
tougher battles than mine
and got to meet their families.
And it's a whole
nother focus for me.
And even if I'm not a
governor, it gives me, I mean,
I'm going to continue to
fight, to help, you know,
raise awareness and raise money
for these terrible diseases.
I mean, so many people
are touched by cancer.
Everywhere I go, because
of my experience,
people know about it,
and they'll tell me,
share their story about
what they went through
or their spouse or their
child, or one of their parents
or somebody, you know,
somebody you love
has been through this before.
And it was, it was
pretty incredible.
- Yeah, did you think
about not coming back
even once you were
on the other side,
just because you didn't
want to deal with the stress
or anything like that?
- You know, they asked me at
my very first press conference
when I announced this news.
And I'll tell you a funny story.
I had to do a biopsy surgery.
They had to take out a lymph
node out from under my arm.
And doctor the said, you know,
"You're gonna to be
fully under anesthesia.
We're gonna give you some
pretty serious painkillers.
So you just gotta
go home and rest."
And I said, "Well, I can't,
I can't go home and rest,
I gotta go do a
press conference."
And he says, "Oh, you can't
do a press conference.
You know, you're
gonna be out of it."
And I go, "Well, I have
to, because I'm gonna go in
to start my 24-hour chemo."
And he goes, "They're not
going to ask you questions
at this press
conference, are they?"
And I go, "Yeah, pretty sure
they're going to
ask me questions."
So I stood up there and took
questions and they were like,
you know, you know, "Are
you going to resign?"
"Is the Lieutenant Governor
going to take over?"
What happens if this and
what happens if that?
And I was sort of on truth serum
because I had all
these drugs in me.
And I just, it was, you know,
it sounded like I was telling
my family in my living room.
I just told the whole public
exactly what was going on.
But I, you know, I never
thought about resigning.
I'm like everybody else
that went through cancer.
I still had to try to, you
know, try to do my job.
And I was working
from the hospital bed.
You know, they were feeding
me full of so much drugs
and you know, I was doing
steroids and I was up all night.
So I was actually working
more from the hospital.
I was texting all night and
telling people, you know,
get this done and get that done.
- Hmm, well, listen, I know
we're tight on time here
so my final question,
since you are in Annapolis
and I mentioned right before
that I get to
Annapolis pretty often,
do you know the name
of that Mexican joint
on Main Street in Annapolis?
They've got some of
the best margaritas
and tacos I've ever had,
and I've been trying
to think of the name the
entire time I'm talking to you.
- That's a really--
- I guarantee one
of your staff knows--
- Well, one of of the staff,
what's the best
place on Main Street?
C'mon.
- The Mexican joint,
that little Mexican
joint, they do--
- There's a whole bunch of 'em.
- They do street tacos.
Oh, it's just great.
- I don't know, but
I'll tell you what,
when you come into Annapolis,
we're going to take you there.
We're going to find out and
we're gonna get you there.
You know, we're going
to get some margaritas
when I see you
here in Annapolis.
- That would be a pleasure.
- Absolutely.
- Well, governor Larry
Hogan, thanks for doing this
and good luck.
- Yeah, Dave, thank you.
Thank you, I enjoyed it.
- All right, and if
you guys know someone
who could appreciate a
different viewpoint, be sure
to share this video by
clicking the share arrow below.
Thanks again, Governor.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety
of topics, watch our
full episode playlists
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.